what does it implementation actually
mean well it's simple as you could say
it's writing a program to do it but of
course there's a lot of infrastructure
behind that when you're devising a
strategy a program to do it one of the
first things you have to think about is
first of all what's the logical
progression of what I'm trying to do in
the program and secondly what kind of
data structures have raised structures
whatever
what infrastructure is needed to support
all that dates a while you're processing
it and different people can have
different ideas about what the best
implementation is I mean for example
we've had recently from Alex Pinkney
linked lists this points to no because
we're browsing NASA and then read a bit
about NASA clicked on the Neill arm for
an article I mean some people are so mad
about linked lists they'd use them for
anything and say yes I implemented it
with linked lists because it was write
data structure for this particular thing
and then once you got the data store you
say ah but I felt that the best
algorithm to use for this because it's
so similar to what he did
Dijkstra's algorithm you know finding
you way from A to B as it were
so the algorithm and the data structure
in fact it's I think Niklaus severe did
a book once called algorithms plus data
structures equals programs so it's down
to saying what's your choice of both of
these things justify why you did it that
way and your implementation may differ
from other peoples implementations
because they don't agree with you that's
the way to do it there's no absolute
right and wrong one's always amazed that
what seems to be absolutely the
definitive way to do it very often
it doesn't is never proved completely
wrong but there's always some little
tweak that you can put on the end and
you find this in things like coding
theory you know we thought this was the
best way to know somebody came up and
said actually no the basis of what
you've done is right but why not at the
tail end do it
his way because that makes their end of
gifts it's a bit in a way like saying
Newton was not wrong
he just only told part of the story and
Einstein supplied the rest and that can
so often happen in programming though
very casually you do get a completely
new idea comes along and say hey we
could tear that up and do it this way
and that's once in a very long time that
is is that the equivalence sometimes
there's somebody turning up to a Formula
one track in a tractor
yes it's going to go around the track
but is it completely unsuitable to all
the wonderful undergrad students who
computer science out there forgive me
yes certainly sometimes you look at
programs that have been handed in and
they really are tractors trying to
compete with with McLaren Formula one
cars but yeah they get round but you
know in a very non optimal way but
sometimes yeah sometimes you know one is
amazed and delighted by the ingenuity
that people can show in their choice of
algorithms and data structures something
really new and I mean back to the other
video I've done about you know poetry to
programming a lot of us feel and some
gasps who said this was it Tony Hoare Oh
Dijkstra danke Nath it is like writing a
poem if you get your implementation your
program to work and you think it's
beautiful
you get a great sense of satisfaction
and somebody does somebody out there
tell me who is just somebody does call
their completed programs poems really
well know yeah I know the feeling
Turing was a shocker for wanting to do
it even though it had been done before
and Fanning's all out for himself
because he didn't want the grooves in
his mind to be polluted by knowing how
other people had done it now that's fine
but at the end when you've done it
you've got to say has anybody done it
differently before and you've then got
to take a stock cheering was a bit of a
shocker for doing it his way and not
checking whether anybody had done it
before if you remember he got his
fellowship with tackling a problem and
he didn't realize till he don't want to
look at how other people might have done
there they gave him the fellowship
anyway but if it's been done for years
earlier but actually his way
had some nice little tweaks in it and
his tutor song do you know that that's
nice that little extra tweet you've done
there it's worth it
so implementation sometimes reinvent the
wheel sometimes just go your own way yes
that's right
[Music]
two lambda expressions here both of
which take two inputs X and Y and one
chooses the first one X and one chooses
the second one y so fair enough what can
we actually do it and designer a
programming language that we all use
which became Haskell